la réponse de ce gouvernement allait non
seulement sécuritaire mais dans ce que
j'entends dans le premier ministre est
qu'il va augmenter d'un cran la sécurité
la répression il va dire il a dit aux
policiers
aller au contact maintenant et que va
répondre que vont répondre c'est à dire
que vont répondre c'est à dire ne pas
rester à distance larmes au quai comme
cela était allé au contact et on fasse
pas le temps de ça vous avez peur mais
en face on va voir qui font face les
pacifistes ils vont pas être là en face
on va voir qui donc on va voir les ultra
violents qui vont aller au contact aussi
savent aller jusqu'où il va y avoir
semblé réellement une force habilite la
france est au bord de la guerre civile
en bord de lac à aller au bout mais là
on va c'est l'escaladé de la violence
dans une once de gouvernement c'est pas
que organise le gouvernement c'est qu'il
y à un affrontement qui s'organise entre
des ultra violente que les vols paris
veulent qu'ils veulent eux ils l'ont ils
le disent d'ailleurs sur leur facebook
leur message on veut s'attaquer aux
symboles de la république aux symboles
de l'état
c'est inadmissible mais bien sûr mais je
vous dis les manifestations du 1er mai
nous pénalise de la même manière les
organisations syndicales ont interposés
les gouvernements sur ça c'est
exactement ce que dit monsieur frédéric
lordon monsieur frédéric lordon qui est
économiste et qui est un proche de
françois ruffin
est-ce que vous condamnez ce type de
propos qui en appelle à l'insurrection
aujourd'hui je la chapelle paris
surrection chapelle à ce que le
gouvernement apporte des réponses
politiques
on doit apporter des réponses politiques
aux problèmes qui se passe dans notre
pays parce qu'ils basculent sur les sacs
aujourd'hui on aujourd'hui c'est un
climat de violence qui se développent et
y compris le gouvernement a décidé
d'augmenter de pousser d'un cran la
répression et du coup c'est l'escaladé